welcome to the 12th ever episode of the
iced coffee hour
hope you're having a good sunday how you
doing doing great hold on let's do this
uh asmr style ready
even is wait hold on you want to go
first we'll go at the same time
ready one two
wow ah you spilt right there oops there
we go
i was told that i needed to hydrate more
so i have some extra drinks just in case
oh good i'm glad my first time trying
this this
watermelon lacroix what do you think
about it because every single time
the podcast starts i offer you a look
right you always say no what
is it like coffee but this one we're
filming late it's like 8 30 p.m i'm not
gonna have coffee this late
uh because then i'm gonna be up all
night i don't want to be up all night
what do you think about it
it's good i actually prefer i don't
really
but what oh come on i'm sorry
okay okay okay
you know what happened we picked up
audio here okay
we'll just cut back in yeah give him a
heads up we'll put this in the beginning
audio cuts out for like 30 seconds and
then it'll come back and it's funny
though
anyway welcome 12th ever episode you
like the lacroix
it's good okay yeah cool
we're professionals we have made how
much graham how much have we made on the
planet i'm gonna guess like 17.50 now
over two thousand dollars no was it
really over here two grand
wow two thousand and eighteen dollars
and fifty cents on the podcast that's
good that means the last few days has
been like 30 bucks
yeah our average is going up i'll throw
up a screenshot of our analytics
our average is going up for yeah
i wonder what it would be after like the
hundredth episode so we would be two
years
into uh podcasting
i don't know if it goes up like
incrementally like like it's it's
ten times more when we have a hundred
videos versus 10
maybe maybe i feel like podcasts are
great because a lot of people would go
back in time
and re-list or listen for the first time
to the really old episodes at least
that's what i do with the podcast i like
like with with different kind of content
i don't really go back because it's kind
of outdated but podcasts
as long as they're not like i don't know
as long as i'm not talking about news
like i like to go back and listen to
i guess yeah i guess so you know what we
can we can almost see
on our analytics and just check if how
much views
so i bet it's mostly the recent video
that's getting
uh the dax flame video let's see what's
that the dax plan is it's not that high
no it's not oh no no yeah it was a seven
it's not good no that's not good that's
you know what it is let's see right now
it's the uh graham makes the riskiest
investment
live on the podcast and uh how to make
80 000
a month those are the ones that are
doing well we have two episodes over 50
000 views
that's awesome look at that the average
every time goes up a little bit so thank
you guys
thanks guys sitting through the ads
thanks for hitting the like button we
got a
good episode for you planned today also
starting this coming week
every wednesday guess what graham
highlights
oh yeah no way you're gonna do
highlights
wow so highlights are gonna be posted on
this channel how you how do you do that
do you like
do you just take the best parts of every
episode and you just
are you gonna do like five to ten minute
clips or how's it gonna work just ten
minutes okay
yeah okay what are you gonna title that
just i guess the topic of whatever
you're saying
uh highlights for this week and then
maybe like a line and then the
what maybe the most exciting thing of
the episode was pick the most exciting
thing in the episode just title it that
how's that yeah no cool so that's
something to look out for maybe not for
you guys if you're already watching
but i don't know maybe we tap into a new
audience that's what i'm hoping yeah
that's what i'm hoping the impatient
people something that's been unfolding
between graham and i and
you know i'm sure you guys are all well
aware as a viewer
is my whole thing with college
you've gotten into it yeah we've gotten
into it and
believe it or not we have made the
decision wait wait you should
here's the thing i've made the decision
yeah
you would have to return to school and
then this podcast would really be
no more i'm doing it for you guys yeah
so you better hit the like button you
want to you want to tell them what you
did yeah
i i dropped out of college dropped out
we got him join join us
so this was very very well thought out
it was not obviously something that
a decision that i made just like this i
i thought it through i talked to
everybody i needed to talk to i got
every opinion i could get
and i honestly never
never would have thought that it was
good never
ever like literally even like a month
and a half ago yeah
no way i agree i can confirm that
because i've been trying to
be like you take a year off and i would
just laugh graham would bring it up to
me and i'd be like oh yeah yeah
i would just blow it off sure man but
it's all very calculated and i just want
to say
for those of you who are in college or
plan to go to college
i still completely stand with what i
would what i would previously say
and what i you know obviously i still
say this now i think college is a really
good idea
i graham and i are different here okay i
think it's a really really good idea
for a decent amount of people for some
people it just doesn't make sense for
example i did the costs
the cost of me going to college and then
possibly losing ties or
all the momentum i've been building with
graham and i did the cost of staying
with graham and
losing that safety net of having a
college degree i did all of the costs i
i analyzed it i talked to my parents i
talked to everybody i could
and it really makes the most sense to
work with graham
money talks it was expensive it was not
it was not
cheap to get
it was a hefty negotiation because it
goes both ways like yeah
this was this was a price that i it took
me like
i talked to so many people there were
like six people that i talked to
i went back and and i really tried my
best not to make impulsive decisions
either so what i would do is i'd be like
okay i need like a few days
to think this through i'm gonna come
back to you with the number i came back
to you with a number
you had a few days you got back to me
and then i think we went back once more
like the whole process took like a week
and a half we shot offers back and forth
a lot of times and just the negotiation
part
that took probably a week maybe longer
than a week i knew
we were gonna get to terms on something
like i knew already
we were going to figure something out i
just didn't know what it was and
yeah i know i did a lot of a lot of uh
cost
and now cost analysis on this and uh i
think it makes sense
yeah so you're gonna get high quality
content
yeah midweek highlights overall
we're going to work really hard as hard
as we can to give you guys the best
stuff we can give yeah do you uh yeah
and uh
i'm i'm excited i'm excited i'm super
excited too i i think good stuff is in
our future it's going to be good yeah
and this is uh i want to say the first
to me now we're going to get into the
next
next year you're going to be like well
now i want to go back to college that's
going to be your negotiation tactic
every year we'll look back at this
every year you'll dangle that little
thing college college by like the tenth
year i'll be like
it's not working this year yeah but i i
still be retired after the tenth year
like i never would have thought that i
i'm still
baffled that i i made that decision so
too late now
yeah it is i i withdrew from classes i
cancelled my quarter and
fortunately obviously oh now i can
renegotiate
we haven't been we haven't signed into a
contract yeah
but but yeah i know yeah really like
what i can do
i'm i will always be a student at ucsb i
talked to the people at the registrar
yeah
uh the admissions and stuff and they
said i could come back whenever i would
like so i didn't lose admission to the
college
i'd like to go to and what's that can
you come back like five years from now
or winston yeah
really yeah are they making exceptions
now because of what's going on
i think so but i i really think that you
can leave and come back as long as you
weren't
dismissed for like academic reasons you
know why
why they want your money that's probably
why yeah it's not even about having good
students like you were good enough once
you're probably good enough like seven
years later yeah if you paid the first
time
you're gonna pay again and what they
know
is that the prices are gonna go up yeah
so if you take two years off they know
that third year
they're charging 15 more so they make
they make money they do yeah it's just
it's crazy guys
don't drop out don't follow in my
footsteps i i had a very very rare
opportunity
and i decided to to take full advantage
of it we're excited
leave me as much hate as you'd like in
the comments no one's gonna leave you
hate everyone's gonna be excited you're
gonna make
make money making money this year yeah
that's the plan
and next year so let's hear it next year
that's the news everybody
that's the t that's our clickbait right
there that's that's the title of the
video today but we got some other
exciting stuff planned
the algorithms they're back in our favor
on this channel it's funny the
algorithms are never good on both
channels
at the same time on oh wait not on this
channel the second channel
second channel we had well we had a one
we had a two
that turned into a three yeah we've had
like you know the grant video was like a
two or a three we've just had banger
after banger
yeah it's been amazing that's that's
what it gets you used to that certain
tier
of views and then you do some growth and
then after a month it slows down and
you're so sad it slows down you wonder
what is going wrong and uh so
right now it's in our favor the main
channel it's slowed down a little bit so
we gotta we gotta boost up that main
channel now it's crazy how it just go
it's just
yeah like that yeah can we say that we
had a record month with the revenue of
the second channel yeah go for it we had
a record
month yeah with the revenue so
previously our record was what like it
was 30.
um like 33 something like that i think
it was
so we had the record
april and no no may june and july were
all just crazy
yeah previously the record was like what
20 28 27 grand 27 28 and then we had
like 30
then like a 34 and then 38 yeah was last
month yeah
which is just insane we had good views
last month oh yeah um
yeah a lot of that was just a few videos
that just did way better than normal the
pokeman video the pokemon i mean that
one did like seven
yeah that was a that was a crazy that
one i didn't expect i honestly i didn't
uh i i didn't i held off from reacting
to that video for a very long time
because i'll get around to it
i didn't expect that at all but i mean i
don't even think we've discussed this on
the podcast but
because of that video we met up with her
i'm sure you guys have all seen but
we met up with her and did a video for
the main channel yeah confronting
pokemon
yeah yeah that was great that was a
spin-off of the uh
anytime i would react to a millennial
money i would try to have them on the
channel and then confront them and it
would be like confronting
so and so for millennial money so now we
confronted pokeman
yeah really smart really smart person
yeah but that was a really actually
one thing i realized is that's a fun
kind of episode to film
it's different and i know it's difficult
for you because you edited
yeah so much yeah that was a nightmare
to do
i mean just the amount of stress going
into it just i didn't want to mess it up
the editing was intense that was my
monday so like no that was my wednesday
video right
that was wednesday a wednesday video it
was a wednesday video so they had to
meet up with
the amount of planning beforehand was
intense
we thought through everything did that
day on that sunday i edited
all day on monday to have that video
ready and posted by wednesday
probably over 20 hours of grams so easy
went into that
easily and guess what what happened to
the video when we posted the number one
which means no no no no oh four oh wow
so get this so so i spent like 20 hours
maybe no a little bit less than that
editing the video a whole day
basically filming the video for the most
part and we probably spent i don't know
six seven hours between both of us
planning out the video it was a night it
was a nine hour day yeah
at filming at pokemon yeah so
ramsay stop it okay so anyway
we post the video and it's all good to
go and within
like i don't know 15 minutes the video
gets
demonetized it was horrible
absolutely horrible and the reason it
gets demonetized is not because like
we violated it there was a little like
four
second clip a sound clip about 18
minutes into the video that i
used from pokemane's video so this was
not audio i put in i was referencing her
video in the background
had a little audio clip in it that got
flagged and i remember you felt
physically sick oh yeah i wanted this
physically sick
he was sitting here just looking at his
computer and
he looked so upset and i felt really
really bad because i know
you spent so much time working on that
video yeah it was
terrible and and here's the thing when
videos like that get demonetized what
ends up happening is that you see your
views
their views went okay but then all of a
sudden starts going down like
dying out a lot youtube's not gonna push
your video if they can't make money on
it and if there's no
if it's technically the way it works is
that ads can be shown but the other
person gets the ad revenue
but i don't know exactly how that works
because that other person might not have
the same
ad rates as me so i don't know anyway
usually when that happens my experience
has been just the video
dies down and here i am like 30
something hours into a video that i put
so much time into
and it just the views are terrible
and and i yeah i i didn't know what to
do so took
deleted the video which i never delete
videos but i had to delete the video
take out that little audio clip
re-upload it
and you can't just re-upload the same
video by the way because no one clicks
on it because they're like oh i already
watched this video the same thing
so you have to re-title it and
re-thumbnail it so here we are we spent
so long in this title and a thumbnail
that we have to redo from scratch last
minute and people are expecting this
video to come up
thankfully we nailed it yeah thankfully
that worked out in our favor and that
couldn't have gone better
yeah so there you guys go aspiring
youtubers
it's not easy even for the man yeah even
the stress now thinking about like it
really left me just like yeah and that
day you
like after that you run you weren't
cloud nine after after we got it
uploaded and it was like out of two or
whatever you were on you were so oh
yeah because she tweeted it out
afterwards and did like an it did she do
an instagram something
yeah i think she did an instagram swipe
up or whatever yeah so both of those
like it was at a two
and then she did that like you sort it
to a one youtube push the video a little
bit
didn't have a lot of longevity
unfortunately i'll check that but
either way i'm really happy with with
how that turned out that was stressful
5100 views last 48 hours as long as it
maybe
just gets 2500 views a day i'd be happy
with that
yep good times oh
follow our instagrams follow follow my
instagram
follow you guys are already all probably
following graham follow her instagrams
sh we should have a joint instagram gram
and jack jack
jack and graham i haven't handled iced
coffee you know what i always like my
name in front like gram and jack
this one sounds better jack and cram i
don't know why yeah you think so or not
i thought graeme and jackson
and jack let us know down below in the
comments jack and graham
graham and jack let us know down below
in the comments
and we're gonna date it from our first
ever time going out and getting these
burgers
yeah we just post every time we're
together we'll just we'll just
post stuff oh ramsay ramsay's doing the
thing
if you guys were wondering if we had to
guess this podcast we do there we go we
got
ramsay ramsay the kitty hey
there he is he's always gonna make a
guest appearance here
there he is also you guys are
real investigators you you have found my
jubilee video
they did they they found it wow they did
they found it okay
how do you know because people were
commenting oh wow yeah so people found
it and then i went to the jubilee video
and i saw comments that were like
this jack from the ice con yeah wow you
have all found it and i would just
ramsey
ramsey she's trying to get out of that
ramsay stop it
wow that i can't believe people have uh
found how there's so many jubilee videos
how would they
like find that video no idea wow
but for those of you who who are curious
uh
i i think my my stances have changed
a little bit i wouldn't say that they
flip-flop but i think that
i've grown and like are you proud of the
things that you said in your
in your videos your jubilee videos or
would you retract any statements that
you've made
no you wouldn't retract any see i'm not
the same way
yeah which is difficult for me because
they obviously i would never ask them to
change it because as a
you know a partial creator like i
understand the feeling of when someone
would ask to like you know remove
content or change content but it's it's
odd because there is some
like not really regrettable but stuff
that i maybe was like ill-informed or
something that i said
i mean i prefer not to bring it up
because it's like you know what i mean
yeah so if you guys find it
enjoy yeah and if not then
hit the like button the twitter hacker
that we were also talking about a while
ago we brought that up a few podcasts
ago
they found him 17. 17 years old yeah
genius kid
crazy yeah and he only got 121 000 in
bitcoin
i feel like what i would have done if i
was 17 is i would have had some sort of
message
because i would want a job just like
i would say something like this account
was hacked reach out to me
for a job like i want a job something
like that because i think
there's no harm there he's not stealing
anything technically
it's illegal but yeah they gotta hire
this guy like anybody
to hire this this kid after that yeah i
mean it was
incredible what he did unless he had
an in with someone at twitter which was
the guest
and they were providing him account info
and then like really what he did was
illegal if he went in and like had
someone in there no i think he was a
part of a hacker group
wow yeah and he was 17 which is just
unbelievable why would he
did he he must have expected it to be up
longer than it actually was
yeah maybe yeah he didn't only take
bitcoin from people that sent him
bitcoin
background just really quickly there was
a guy that hacked twitter
and then sent he made famous people send
a message that said like send me
this amount of money i'll send you twice
that amount of money back in bitcoin or
whatever
and he got 121 thousand dollars and he
made like steve jobs do elon musk a
bunch of famous people
um but yeah i mean just
it seems like a waste a real waste of
talent oh i agree
i was i was hearing jokes that like the
federal government would want to hire
this guy on to like
be like a internal hacker or whatever
yeah it's like the the movie catch me if
you can
where he he forges checks and then they
catch him he goes to jail but then he
then
works for the fbi later for like you
know fraudulent checks
and uh it seems like something like that
would happen
but yeah no i just it seems like a lot
too much work to go through
to save up or to make 120 grand that
this
does he get to keep he couldn't keep the
money bail was set i think around 121
grand
and i'm sure he does not get to keep the
money but he also
he also stole some handles so what he
did was he took
like a handle like vampire just like
random handles that are probably worth
some amount of money
right that would probably be a better
crime
to take some handles that nobody uses
really
and just get it like you have to handle
peter yeah john like some of these
things find somebody who hasn't posted
in years
right instagram has that uh they have it
where
allegedly uh if someone has not used an
account for like
many years and you want to take their
domain name there's ways that you could
do that
you got to pay some money to do that but
it's possible
yeah so i don't know why why you
wouldn't just do that because he could
probably make 200 300 grand like no one
would know
yeah and and people would think like oh
maybe i just forgot my password to
at john you know i don't know
maybe yeah that's what i that's what i
would have done
so graham options trading okay
i know this is not one of your favorite
topics sure i'm six for six
what's your total return now over four
and a half percent
you made four and a half percent on six
trades
yeah that doesn't seem like a lot here's
the thing it's because when you view
options trading you see it as a super
risky investment
right those are the people that are
getting like 30 40 percent
for over four and a half percent in
about a month is pretty good
yeah but that's what the s p 500 has
done this last month they've gone up
about
maybe more than that is it yeah
so let's say if you just invest in the s
p 500 we go back one month
it was 31.45 a month ago
and now it's 33.50 31.45
oh yeah all right yeah you would be up
about six and a half percent had you
just invested once in the s p
and left it regardless six out of six is
not bad
okay and i think i can continue on this
road i've made
like 140 profit so far locked in
i went from three thousand to three
thousand one hundred forty i lost thirty
five dollars in dogecoin
but i am i'm i'm in the green and i'm
going to continue
in the green until i'm 20 for 20. good
and then we'll have a different talk
okay deal okay 20 for 20. what what did
i say again i forgot
you didn't say anything you just said
you'll finally be impressed
yeah i'm not in print i'm not you have a
20 for 20 you'll be like how much profit
you make
seven percent i'm an inexperienced
trader yeah like i'm
i'm new to this right so being
inexperienced six for six i think is
pretty impressive not to toot my own
horn yeah but like
all right let's see 20 for 20. all right
keep doing it uh on on a new subject
graham you're now a tick talker yeah i
am
and a successful one at that i don't
know successful you have over 20 000
followers
20 i'm 24 right now it's been growing by
like a few thousand a day
graham is going to be the next big tick
tocker watch out
hype house graham's moving in
one thing that really surprised me in
the news is jobless claims
for this past month were the lowest that
they've been
since the beginning of like the whole
like unemployment people are getting
back to work like early april
yeah or whatever yeah early april the
lowest they've ever been so
1.2 million claims about a little under
they've leveled off
it's it's always been above a million
yeah
it's it's leveling off but still it's at
the lowest it's ever been they were
expecting 1.4
and i'm just wondering if this is
actually gonna like how much
you know the damage that we've done to
the market is going to affect the future
market
it seems like we're still doing fine
right
and i i i can imagine that we continue
going in this direction but i'm just
wondering because
intuitively it just seems like we're
gonna there's no way we're not headed
towards a crash or something
a million people is still a lot it's a
lot of people that
still continue to be claiming
unemployment
um who knows who knows i have a feeling
they're going to continue the
unemployment benefit a little bit longer
they
might already come out by now by the
time this video comes out
but i have a feeling they'll continue
that to some degree probably it'll be
four or 450 a month
that'll hold us over to the end of the
year it's really it's just this waiting
game right now for a vaccine
or something that might be moderately
effective that's really all this is at
this point
because even if they come out with
something that's 50 effective
essentially half of the population could
get back to work and not have to worry
about it and
for hospitals too i mean that would
allow the people who do get it
to uh get the care they need
i'm just scared for the future at some
point you tell me that i should have
more invested than i currently do
but i just i'm just so scared because i
am i just can't
ah you're young it doesn't matter
like when you're 60 you're not going to
be the oh i should have invested a 25
instead you would no no one's going to
fake that i'll do it
yeah i'll do it all right just do it as
soon as you invest let me know so i
could sell
because the market is going to tank yeah
i don't okay yeah and you'll be like i
should have done options trading instead
yeah i probably should have
one thing that i found really
interesting that you and i were talking
about earlier today
on our run which we've been doing later
yeah it's good being nice and healthy
yeah you were talking about your first
ever rental property that you got and
you got that at 21 years old
right yep which i mean it's like i'm 21
right now i can't picture myself buying
a rental property you probably were in a
better financial position than i was but
but still i mean how how much was the
house that you bought
59 59 500 i think a public record it
shows
60 500 and i was able to get i feel bad
now but i was able to get a credit back
outside of escrow for a thousand dollars
and did you get a better deal because
you were an agent probably within the
no i actually had an agent that was
representing me who quit
because it was a difficult client wow
dead yeah
absolutely dead serious on that um
yeah so she represented me i was writing
all these offers and i figured
it was better to do it through her
because i didn't really care about the
commission
anyway and i wanted someone to help me
like get to know the area i should reach
out to her actually
she'd find her and give her money what
ended up happening was that
she just was not on top of it like i was
used to this level of customer service
where like
i wanted to write offers on properties
and she would be
okay you know i'm gonna be out tonight
and i'll get back late and then i'll do
it tomorrow and i'm thinking like
no no the place just came on the mark
like we gotta get the offer now like
today
uh oh no i'll do it and then and then
apparently me pushing like why can't you
just do it when you get home tonight
like
i'll be up send it to me at 10 11
o'clock and uh
that stressed her out she was an older
agent and i don't think she was used to
that like
like beverly hills is one of those
industries where
everyone is on it like you call the
agent and like if they're in the middle
of dinner they'll set up a showing for
like
that that's what i was used to i was
hard on her
and there were just just so many things
with with writing offers
with negotiating deals that she just
didn't want to do
and even when it came to um
asking for for certain credits during
inspection her telling me no i'm like
why don't we just write it up and ask no
please do it and then we would do it and
i'd end up getting something
but um i forget what happened exactly
but i just
she quit she quit on me and she said
that she couldn't represent me anymore
and she just let me represent myself
and i think at the time i mean i i had
no money i mean no money
when i bought these properties like i
was out of cash so like every little
scent mattered to me but uh i was
aggravated with her because i felt like
i could have gotten deals quicker or i
could have
negotiated a little bit harder if it
wasn't for her so
she quit i represented myself should
find her
but it was it was a sixty thousand
dollar property yeah
and so you only needed how much down
what price i bought it cash
oh wow so you paid sixty thousand
dollars that's really good
and and you were immediately it was
immediately a good investment
yeah oh yeah i rented it out right
afterwards
well not right like a month afterwards i
think i got
it was either 1150 1200 or 12.50 i don't
know this was back in
this would have been like early 2012.
early to like january february 2012.
somewhere around there
so you bought it a good time yes it was
immediately a good investment you bought
it under market value
right you fixed it up a little bit yeah
i spent 12 000 fixing it up
got it under contract in like 2011. so
this was like took a while for this deal
to go through
and what gave you the idea of investing
in real estate
uh clients were doing it that that area
of san bernardino i had a
wealthy dude in beverly hills who was
buying up everything left and right just
didn't care
sight on scene wouldn't even go out
there to see it just had a team of
people and all he would do is just
just write off or write off right off
right off or just anything that comes up
write an offer and so after a while and
seeing like wow he's making some good
money from this
i had all this money saved up and i
wasn't sure where to invest it and i
figured this is a good option for me
so i started going out there and i would
go spend every weekend
with uh with a buddy june what's up i
don't know if june's watching this but
uh june's watching this
so we used to go out him and i and go
like look at places
every single uh weekend we drive up
spend like a day there see
like 15 14 places come back
get to know the market and uh it just
determined it was a really good
investment out there
did june buy property he did yeah he
bought a problem yeah
and um and then the other guy who i was
working with the time his name was uh
vigili bought a property up there too
yeah so yeah and then energy is good
yeah and you immediately i mean you were
stoked with your investment yeah and
then how long did it take for you to get
your next
rental so i got three up there
around the same time so i used all the
cash i had i sold
the lotus elise that i had at the time
because i needed cash
and uh got three up there and then it
wasn't then i had to save another few
years
to get the next one the next one was
like 2 000
gosh 15 i think
so this is 2012 13. so three it took me
three years then after that to go and
save up for another property
and what do you think has been the
average roi
on your real estate i don't even know
i don't know um good
like what 15. wait including
appreciation uh
oh god i i don't know like like the
first few places
have gone and have like 5xed in value
yeah okay so those have all gone up the
next place
i'm i was in it eight
twenty to eight i don't know i don't
know these numbers
i was i i was in the the fourth place
sorry there's so many of them i was in
the fourth place like
8 20. now it's worth
about one three
the next spot i bought for 585
fixed it up i don't know maybe i'm in it
now like a hundred so i'm in it like
6.85
no more than that maybe i'm in at 7 20
and uh it's worth about a million
next spot i bought for 8.15
it's probably also worth about a million
and
uh is there anything else in this place
then this place which it's probably
worth about my guess about five percent
more than what i
what i'm in it about five percent
but i closed on this place earlier this
year so really a lot of that is just the
hype
right now around right everything going
on i just want to get invested in real
estate so badly i'm an
eager young teen
21 yeah and i want to get in real estate
but i can't
so expensive here you you would need to
save up have like 150 grand
yeah saved up if you want to buy real
estate around here you could do that two
years two years of saving
after taxes would do that to you really
two years of saving after tax
that's my plan i want to buy my first
rental 23 or younger
that's that's my goal you could do it i
mean right not right now
i mean you could buy a rental you could
go to like you know some of these states
where you could buy rentals for like 80
grand
yeah it depends where you want to buy
while perusing the internet
i i once again found something powerful
money questions i i heard that people
liked that segment
from from a few episodes ago so i've
came up with a few more
money questions to ask we can answer so
is my money being spent on the things
that truly matter to me
that's for you yes
such as
this this table it's a table no this is
a bad decision
um honestly this money's just really
mattered to me
yeah i mean i don't spend money though
like we you and i got chipotle the other
day
macy and i got cheesecake factory
what else do i need i don't i don't
think that you're really satisfied by
material
things being bagged the aquarium i'm
still putting that off because i don't i
don't know
maybe maybe at some point if if i uh
if i end up moving out of state at some
point i don't want this crazy aquarium
here that i can't take care of
every few days what is your plan with
your children and your money
how many kids are you planning on on
having one to two one to two and what's
your plan with him
with money i mean ideally i'd wanna give
them
most of it but i i think i would also
donate a portion to charity
it depends how much i have like if it's
like a billion dollars obviously i
wouldn't
leave anyone a billion dollars if it's
like
20 million i think that would be more
manageable
uh you set it up in a trust and you just
you let them spend whatever the interest
is
but ideally like in a dream growing up
kids what
kids growing up oh
i'd want them to work i really want them
to put them to work and teach them the
value of money that's what i think i
mean i have no idea
i'll probably wing it but i would want
them to get jobs
and uh you know chores probably just do
stuff
i kind of always i i like the idea of
telling my kid to get a job because
hopefully if i'm if i'm wealthy enough
you know like my kids
they see like i think it puts you a
little bit at a disadvantage
if if you grow up in a household that
you can tell is it's a nice house you
know like maybe you have
like a four-room house like three
bathrooms it's like a bigger house
you can tell from your friends that
you're a little bit wealthier i think
that that probably
makes you think less of the dollar yeah
having like having more to choose from
and stuff just
just naturally you have a higher
standard yes of living oh yeah
i think something that could that could
help out with that
what i would do is is i would tell my
kid to get a job say the job is paying
ten dollars an hour
i would give them five extra dollars per
per ten dollars they made off that job
okay so they would get a little bit more
you know that's in the in the event that
i do have enough money to do something
like that i would give them a little bit
more reason you know what i mean yeah
and then what's gonna happen when
they're out of college like
but dad i got five hundred thousand
dollars out of school
with your friends you need to match it
no you're right yeah dad yeah
i don't know i i think just get a job
work i think that teaches them the value
of money very quickly
yeah it's something i think about a lot
i don't think there's one set solution
no but definitely a complicated
situation
we're moving on to a new segment are you
excited yes i am
it's called what's in your wallet i
don't have my wallet on my oh it's right
there
i just thought of this like a couple
minutes ago do you want to do it
sure oh okay so i got uh three credit
cards
right there i got the jp morgan reserve
i got the amex platinum and i got the
amex gold business
got my driver's license i got the chase
sapphire
reserve here and then behind it i have
my priority pass
card for the no traveling i'm doing
right now
behind my driver's license i have my aaa
card
this might actually have expired
geez i can't i can't even pull it out do
you want some help with that
no no it's just the leather sticks to it
yeah
it expired a year ago look at that
i'm gonna keep it in there just in case
the number's still good though just in
case
and then what do i have on the inside
actually a lot of stuff on the inside
okay so i have
that's where it went
i was looking for this this is uh free
parking anywhere in vegas
at those hotels it's the m life platinum
wow
yeah oh wow i was looking everywhere for
this and i couldn't find it
it doesn't have your name on it no it
doesn't it's it's it's a friends
who gambles a lot and he was he gave me
this card so
i just get free oh free valet too and uh
wow uh certain vegas casinos so there we
go
uh i got a habit burger gift
card uh picture of me and macy here
tesla card hsbc
uh debit card oh wait make sure that
people
i got an hsbc debit card here this is a
free debit card withdrawals so what they
do
is that for what is this the hsbc
premiere they reimburse you for any
debit card fees or like uh sorry
uh what do you call it cash
withdrawals atm oh sorry uh so i use
this card for atm withdrawals if i need
to because they reimburse you for the
hsbc premiere for like
anything so even if it's like eight
bucks it doesn't matter
you take out the money it's fine
citibank city gold
city gold debit card when's the last
time you use that i never use it
they they give it to you when you when
you have an account uh oh and then i
that's too bad i have those the beers
free chick-fil-a meals and then a dollar
and that's uh that's my wallet right
there you have one dollar
in it yeah i have one dollar when's the
last time you paid in cash
uh casinos so like that's the only thing
i'll put like a dollar in the uh
so let's put a dollar in the uh like the
slot machine or whatever
huh it's so interesting to look at money
now because it just like you don't
this this is going to be a thing in the
past at some point yeah
people are going to look at this be like
wow
dogecoin it's interesting because really
you
don't really have money like this
anymore not really
save your money people yeah someday
it'll be worth something
one day all right what's in my wallet
first off i have my chase debit card my
expired chase debit card
venmo venmo card nice pretty exciting
they send you a like a free card and you
can get like a cool color that's the
reason why i have it
that's literally it um
auto insurance chiropractic
appointment reminder nice a loyalty
stamp card for bootables
okay
[Music]
um dude i got a lot of stuff in here
license
and life there we go i got an m life
dude i had another one of those
chick-fil-a oh you did i thought i used
them all
oh this is a good one too because this
one will give you a sandwich fries and a
drink
try using it again no i've tried really
yeah i have expired ones still that
aren't the good ones
like the breakfast sandwich and stuff
like that and they turn them down whoa i
didn't even know i had a chipotle card
in there wow that's pretty exciting
guess how much money i have graham
probably 20 bucks
20 40 45 50.
54 i remember when i used to keep cash
like that in a in a wallet and 54 bucks
is a lot of money i remember thinking
like wow like
i got like 320s in there that's that's i
don't know why i have 54.
oh yeah here's a fun story graham and i
were
cleaning out his old duplex and remember
there was there was a woman that like
sent money to you on accident
oh yeah so there was a woman and she
sent money to graham
when she actually meant to send it to
like a family member
it came to my address and it came to his
and she because she wrote down the wrong
address and graham was like oh i'm going
to send it back to her so he left it in
the envelope and he forgot about it
yeah and then like three years later
when we're cleaning out his duplex i
find it deep way back in the
the end of a drawing like graham what is
this it was like it was like three
hundred dollars
it was a lot of money that she was being
sent from like a family member for
graduation
or something like that yeah and and i i
found i was like what is this
doing here you're just like oh wow like
i forgot about that
you know i accidentally received this
money so i made it a mission
to find this girl and i did facebook i
did instagram i looked everywhere
and i found her that's true i found her
and i then mowed her 300 and i kept the
cash
that's why i have all the cash and then
i i just pay my gas
okay cash and i'm you know it's
dwindling down wow i forgot about that
yeah you're right
yeah you found her yeah she's got to be
so appreciative of that
she was weirded out because i i mean
first off i had to verify that i had the
right person i was like
who was it sent by and she was like my
uncle was like the first letter is
r what is the full name and she likes i
mean like we had to go through the
process
i want to send the wrong person but yeah
she was she was weirded out she was
stoked yeah cool
you just van motor like 300 bucks wow
payday
what if it was the wrong person they
just got lucky well
you know it happens
cool chase freedom unlimited
oh rip dude all right ow
rest in peace nice my ucsb card
call and that's about it cool
exciting stuff that is good stuff what's
in my wallet we'll do this every week
i'm watching my wallet this is going to
change very much it's the same thing
that's what's in my wallet cool is there
i mean is there anything else that you
wanted i think that's i think that's it
i gotta edit now
yeah i'm gonna edit my tomorrow video
yeah
all right cool so with that said you
guys
thank you so much for watching i really
appreciate it make sure to subscribe
like add us on instagram hit the
notification bell
get your two free stocks down below in
the description with weeble what else do
we need to tell them
subscribe to the second channel
subscribe to grandma graham's main
channel
the mentorship group is down below in
the description join the mentorship
group and you can talk to us one on one
well in a group one kind of kind of
one-on-one yeah
cool guys thanks guys for watching and
until till next time